[Musique]
l'idée c'est de rassembler un petit peu
tous les acteurs de la ville les
associations petites entreprises autour
du monde de la culture mais également de
faire venir l'intégralité des quartiers
qui se rassemble ici dans ce lieu
central pour fêter une journée très
familiale très festive et très
sympathique
[Musique]
ça commence l'après midi par le pôle jeu
qui est essentiellement centré pour les
enfants bien sûr ce sont des jeux en
bois des jeux assez dimensionnants après
on a bien sûr le pôle dense ou là pour
la plupart ce sont les associations qui
ont préparé un spectacle pour se
produire en fin d'année au niveau du
festival et puis on a bien sûr des
démonstrations
circassiennes on aime bien valoriser un
petit peu la rurbain également et on a
de la musique
[Musique]
alors on a la chance à plaisir d'avoir
une mosaïque culturelle importante
puisqu'on a près de 40 ethnies
différentes pic cohabitent en toute
sérénité l'idée donc c'est évidemment de
permettre à chacun un petit peu de
valoriser sa culture ou de venir
découvrir la culture du voisin
[Musique]